bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'apple une fois n'est pas coutume on va
parler du prochain iphone de l'iphone 8
aces de l'iphone 10 live je sais pas
comment l'appeler un iphone version 8
est ce qui pourrait être en couleur
c'est assez intéressant c'est une
question qui vient de se poser donc du
coup on va regarder ça ensemble on y va
comme d'habitude maintenant
avant toute chose il faut qu'on parle de
quelque chose il ya pas mal de truc qui
arrive à alors effectivement enfin deux
là peuvent vendre des iphone n'y a pas
que ça là j'ai plein plein de trucs vous
êtes au courant déjà on gagne en ce
moment des smartphones des défauts ce c7
vous avez les lire la description du
concours je vous le remet encore en jeu
à vous pouvez encore aller vous inscrire
tout de suite quand je tourne la vidéo
attention dans quelques mois ce sera
trop tard là on a aussi des coques à
gagner de smartphones les steaks
il ya d'autres trucs qui arrive ça c'est
croise ça c'est un smartphone qu'on va
tester d'ici très peu de temps un
produit de chez régis gasse est donc ça
aussi rester connecté vous allez voir ça
va être franchement super cool et là on
a autre chose qui vient d'arriver il ya
très très longtemps
ce sont des coques que je vais vous
faire gagner aussi à des [ __ ]
shield donc donc on en reparle d'ici
quelques temps ouais ils sont super
belle première fille découvre en direct
ne les connaissais pas ah ouais sont
super joli aussi non donc tout ça on va
le faire gagner un voyage de ceux qui
perd coule donc bon rester connecté tout
ça vous allez voir c'est franchement
vers la bombe atomique j'étais de tout
péter et puis c'est pas terminé autre
nouveauté vous savez je sais pas si vous
avez suivi mais l'agent ché oui qu il ya
eu le lancement officiel du vieux de pro
donc et pas mal de petites choses alors
bien évidemment sur ico vous avez le
petit carnet le stylo les lunettes de
soleil
il est surtout on va tester le view deux
pros que j'ai ici
donc ça c'est plutôt la bonne nouvelle
donc rester connecté au niveau parce que
on va le tester il va falloir une boxing
va faire un test un peu complet donc je
le prenne un peu en main des choses que
ça dit donc voilà donc ça c'est pour
voir qu'ils vont montrer capable de
choses qui arrivent donc c'est super
super super cool mais aujourd'hui ce qui
nous intéresse les anis et surtout de
parler justement d'apple et de cet
iphone je sais pas comment l'appeler est
ce que c'est un iphone 10 light est ce
que c'est un iphone il 8 aces c'est un
peu un point d'interrogation justement
comme d'hab
j'ai potassé selon les rumeurs les
prochaines y aura trois nouveaux iphone
y aura deux iphone avec un écran oled y
en aura un qui fera à 5,8 pouces et 1 6
5 pouces tu devrais faire et il y en a
un qu'il va arriver qu'un écran lcd de
6,1 pouces et donc justement cet écran
lcd de 6,1 pouces sera différent des
autres parce que vous soyez donc coûter
beaucoup moins cher but qui va avoir un
écran lcd ça sera un smartphone g1 est
plus abordable en termes de budget et
qui dit plus abordable dit forcément m
cible un peu plus jeunes et qui dit
cible un peu plus jeunes dits produits
peut-être un peu plus fun et des
guillemets tous les produits sont fans
mais surtout la grosse question qui se
pose c'est pour apple
comment réussir à sortir trois produits
a vraiment les différencier on voit que
le smartphone avec l'écran oled vous
allez voir deux tailles une taille se
dirait standard de 5,8 pouces puis un
beaucoup plus grand de 6,5 pouces mais
il se ressembleront fondamentalement ils
vont vraiment se ressemblent et
smartphones caméra trop d'absents koch
grand écran validons se ressembler la
grande différence avec la taille de
l'écran ce avec la taille de la bête à
taille de boîtiers là sauf qu'avec ce
produit si nous sorte un iphone je
dirais un iphone 10 light ou low cost ou
tout ce qu'on peut avec un écran lcd 1
6,1 pouces comment on va le différencier
du 6 5 pouces et du 5 au 8 août si ce
n'est la taille et pour pouvoir
différencier la taille il faut avoir les
autres à côté pour comparer donc s'ils
se ressemblent comment va pouvoir
réellement les identifier et c'est
justement ça tout l'intérêt cette
manière qu effectivement ces analyses
qui a vu ce qu'il pense qu'il y assez
assez juste la source et june zinc ou
d'une langue
excusez moi monsieur lang qui analyse
pour rosenblatt securities et qui a filé
l'afua apple insider qui effectivement
dit que pour différencier ses produits
il pourrait tout simplement avoir des
couleurs un peu comme konami sur
l'iphone 5 sec
d'ailleurs j'en ai un ici l'iphone 5
c'est à partie du truc
un iphone 5 c bleu donc du coup ses
smartphones on pouvait retrouver dans
différentes couleurs on peut retrouver
en raw
en bleu il y avait quoi encore il y
avait le jaune le vert le vert est ok
mais levait roskam et un jaune je vous
dis des conneries je vérifie qu annonce
que j'ai noté je sais plus bon sens pris
les couleurs donc il y aura un
smartphone de couleurs un iphone qui
pourrait être un iphone 10 light un
iphone s ii est ce un iphone 8 s
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
s'il nous faut en effet nuit est ce tout
simplement un iphone 8 aces c'est à dire
qu'on va donner une note des dominations
pour pas à lui de la domination iphone
10 ou iphone 10,2 je sais pas encore
comment il va s'appeler mais si ça
d'iphone ou 8 s est ce qu'il aura le
design le design dizaine est ce qu'il
aura le design de l'iphone 8
est ce qu'il aura encore ce que c'est
quand même dingue qui est vachement
désuet ces grandes banques en hausse et
grandes banques en bas franchement c'est
désuet ça se fait tout lui est ce qui
ressemblera à ça ou alors est ce qu a
contrario il gardera le design de design
j'arrive plus à parler est ce qu'ils
écoutent est ce qu a contrario il aura
le design de l'iphone 10 avec tout
simplement des couleurs pourront plus se
différencier la question maintenant qui
se pose c'est s'il a le design de
l'iphone 10
est ce qu'il aura la caméra trou d'eps
parce que si on veut faire un smartphone
moins cher donc c'est jacques lafleur un
petit peu économiser donc déjà du point
de vue l'écran mais la caméra trop d'eps
je pense aussi que le fils d'équipé ça
coûte cher sur un smartphone donc d'un
autre côté sur - smartphone pas cher et
forcément faire des économies sur
l'écran on va faire sur la canebière un
trou d'air qui dit pas de caméra trop
d'eps dit un bouton home
ça me semblerait très surprenant
qu'apple nous mettre un bouton
déverrouillage au dos de l'appareil pour
tous ce serait ça serait vraiment très
très très bizarre et ça ne ressemblerait
pas du tout donc il ya peu ces deux
questions alors d'un point de vue très
personnel je suis assez partagé
j'imagine que pour des questions de
coûts très clairement d'écrans lcd ça
vaut le coup mais désavoué un peu ces
nouvelles techno en regardant un écran
avec une grande barre en haut une grand
bond en bas comment trouver sur la
feuille 8 et 8 plus ça me semble
franchement franchement aujourd'hui
complètement le school et je serais très
surpris qu'ils le fassent donc j'imagine
j'imagine qu'on va retrouver un iphone
avec un grand écran 6,1 pouces lcd de la
couleur derrière une caméra trop d'eps
et voilà voilà un peu envoyez pour ce
portrait robot je sais pas vous dites
moi ce que vous en pensez parce que ça
c'est vraiment tout qui fait débat
est-ce que ce smartphone s'il sort
effectivement
le coloré ou même 100 d'eau colorée est
ce que vous pensez que le modèle low
cost lcd 6,1 pouces aura la caméra trop
d'eps oui non est ce qu'il aura
l'encoche oui non et ce qu'il aura le
bouton on espère voir ses grandes bord
en haut et en bas vous marquez tout ça
en commentaire parce que ça mérite
vraiment en tout cas de poser la
question alors y'a d'autres rumeurs qui
qui sortent sur les iphone justement je
vous en cite est de 3 comme ça qu on en
reparlera plus tard parce que vous savez
on en parle quand même plutôt pas mal
c'est vrai que les rumeurs iphone c'est
vachement intéressante ça permet un
petit peu de terreau et ressentir ce qui
arrive à l'avenir on sait qu'apple est
franchement très influent et dès qu'il
fait quelque chose dès que la marque
sort un produit tendance à être suivi
que le contraire bien que bien que sur
l'iphone dit sont plus diaphane qu'ils
ont pompé à droite à gauche ont pris un
problème est un peu le meilleur mais on
sait que dans tous les cas une fois
qu'apple se positionne sur un segment
tout le monde les suit le monde c'est la
même chose donc on a une rumeur qui est
assez fraîches et qui dit qui
sous-entend qu'on pourrait trouver sur
l'iphone 10 haut de gamme pour que cette
fois-ci l'iphone dit 5,8 pouces et le
6,5 pouces peut-être même que sur le
site de 5 pouces un triple capteur photo
l'arrière un peu le même système qu'on
retrouve actuellement sans le huawei p20
pro donc effectivement il pourrait s'en
inspirer du mauvais peuvent imposer de
façon il est très clair que sur les
produits très haut de gamme apple va
être complètement obligé de se mettre au
niveau de la concurrence notamment de
samsung avec son galaxy s 9 plus soit
ils auraient effectivement en ouverture
variable comme les snuff plus soit il
aura le 3 capteurs le triple capteur que
dis-je comme ça le mauvais plaisants pro
donc ça s'est un peu voilà cette rumeur
qui fait état d'un potentiel qui peut
capteur photo qu'on peut imaginer sur le
dise plus et une autre rumeur qui fait
état qui ferait état en tout cas d'une
caméra trop deg ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver à l'arrière pourrait
effectivement faire à maintenir en trois
dimensions alors bon ça je le prends pas
réellement avec des pinces et parce que
lorsque vous avez entre votre iphone
dans la main qu'ils fassent un mapping
avec une projection infrarouge sur notre
visage ça me paraît pas de déco nan
parce que vous êtes l'ami à proximité
c'est pas très loin ça fonctionne si
maintenant vous allez prendre un paysage
en photo j'imagine que l'infrarouge pas
aller jusqu'au bout du jardin pour
repérer qui est un arbre intérêt les
fleurs et signer ça il devrait avoir une
certaine proximité peut-être que sur les
prises de photos pour photographier des
amis ça pourrait avoir un sens pour
effectivement sur une vraie belle
profondeur de champ pourquoi pas ça
s'est un peu dubitatif là dessus on
avant d'avoir quelques infos
supplémentaires
voir réellement ce que ça dit si ça se
fait oui non en attendant on voit que
ces rumeurs sont intéressants parce
qu'on se rapproche de plus en plus déjà
du tableau d'ici qui va avoir lieu d'ici
très peu de temps
restez connectés parce qu'on va en
parler très prochainement va suivre les
nouveautés voir les tendances vers ce
qu'il fait en attendant l'iphone et ce2
on attend des nouveaux macbook qu'on
n'attend pas mal de choses on attend
aussi
eyeos 12 ans n'attend pas mal de
nouveautés des surprises donc rester
connecté parce qu'on en parlait
énormément vole un peu pour faire un
point sur cet iphone 8 s iphone 10 light
iphone s ii est ce plus monde et prend
encore non on a un peu largué donc comme
d'habitude vous invite à me laisser des
jolies pouce aux marques et toutes vos
questions suggestions directement en
commentaire en dessous à vous abonner
parce qu'à plein plein plein plein de
choses qui arrivent des surprises des
cadeaux des infos des esprits libres
enfin anna de tous les côtés donc rester
connecté merci à vous a pas regarder
cette vidéo je vous dis à très bientôt
soyez sages et d'ici là je vous embrasse
et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]